but we begin with some terrifying
weather in the south at least 14
tornadoes were reported along the Gulf
Coast Coast yesterday one of them east
of Houston caused extensive damage
remarkably no one was killed Janet
shamlin is on the ground in Deer Park
Texas Janet good morning
Nate good morning to you we were on the
ground here just after the storm people
telling us that seeing the amount of
structural damage there is they are
surprised and grateful that no one was
seriously hurt but this morning much of
this community remains in the dark and
there's a lot of work ahead
a tornado tearing across Orange Texas
this couple make a run for it from their
trailer grabbing their dogs and diving
into a ditch they're okay later saying
they're thankful to be alive
what the dude an hour West a
tornado ripping through Pasadena outside
Houston heavily damaging these
apartments and ripping the roofs from
nearby homes
damage across the Houston area a semi
flipped on its side downed power lines
and trees blocked streets and this gym
shredded people hid in the restrooms
Travis Smith is the owner the metal was
crashing the glass was breaking out it
was extremely loud
fast-moving storm delivered wind gusts
up to 50 miles an hour
and pounding grain flooded streets
across a wide swath of a city in nearby
Deer Park the tornado cut through a
nursing home the mayor saying all 62
residents evacuated safely did you have
any idea it would be this bad not a no
not not even close Edward Salazar owns
this heavily damaged shopping center and
told me he knew there were people inside
at the time what was her first thought
when you drove up and saw this I was
worried about the employees especially
Little Caesars when I I saw what
happened to theirs but everyone was okay
thank God they all climb inside of the
walk-in freezer and hid Lauren Greene
brought his wife to a doctor's
appointment at the center saying his
teenage son survived riding out the
storm in their car I tried to come to
tell him to come inside and by the time
I reached the door
yeah I mean all you can see was like
debris and stuff so I was pretty scared
for my son because he was uh inside his
truck the whole time
schools in this community Deer Park will
be closed today that's a function of the
power outages and the road closures here
and the weather service will be on the
ground looking at the damage to
determine the strength of the tornado
Gail
thank you Janet I think not looking so
great there